[Music]
thank you everybody for attending our
session here today my name is Chris
Latimer I'm one of the product managers
for Google that focuses on api's and API
management before we start the talk
today I'm curious have any of you or how
many of you have been in a session where
we've done questions and answer is using
dory ok so it's new to a bunch of you so
this is this is a internal Google tool
that we use all the time for big
sessions like this where we want to make
sure that not only you have a chance to
ask your questions but also that from an
audience perspective you can vote up and
vote down questions so we can make sure
that we're addressing and answering the
things that you feel are you know the
most important as a group and of course
we'll have mics here and over here as
well so when we get to the Q&A portion
of the talk feel free to step up to the
microphone and we'll be happy to answer
any questions that you may have so a
little bit of background on on me so I
joined Google about two years ago before
that I was working for a company called
apogee a lot of you may have heard of
apogee we're an api management platform
we got bought by Google and so for the
last four or so years I've been spending
almost all my time talking with
customers different companies about the
API programs that they're creating the
challenges they're running into you
trying to figure out how it is that we
can build a platform that's going to
make our customers that the most
successful as we can and before that I
was interested in api's because I was
building a lot of api's and when I when
I first started getting into API there
was a big debate sort of raging in
industry between things like should we
use soap or should we use rest and at
the time it seemed like soap it
basically won enterprises were viewing
api's as this sort of a novelty
technology for the Facebook's and
Twitter's of the world and not really
something that serious enterprises would
need or be rebuilding to satisfy their
use cases and then a couple things
happen we had things like big
improvements in the way that websites
worked so we went from pages that needed
to
every time two single page apps that are
much more responsive and if you look at
frameworks like angular and others that
have come out they natively consume this
JSON and so all of a sudden we had
enterprises building api's to support
these these new types of websites and
then of course at the same time mobile
just became you know it's the explosion
that became and as a result the same
type of thing applied so if you've ever
tried to consume a soap service from say
like an iOS app or build an iOS app that
uses soap it's a pretty challenging
exercise it's pretty trivial if you're
using a restful api and so we had a lot
of companies that we're starting to
build more and more and more api's and
so it's great that today we're sitting
here and in the sort of this you know
completely filled room talking about api
is and somewhat surprising that so even
though it was sort of the de facto
winner is you know i'm i'm pretty
surprised if we find a soap session how
to build better soap services on App
Engine or how to optimize your
kubernetes cluster for soap but we've
got a lot of people that are interested
in an API management so a lot of you are
probably like why are you talking about
the history of API so what's this has to
do with anything I came to a best
practices talk so the reason why I like
to start this talk by sort of describing
a little historical context is that the
circumstances that that sort of happened
around web and mobile led to a bunch of
API programs sort of springing up just
out of necessity without a lot of
foresight and this gives us the ability
to go and sort of look at a lot of
common problems that have happened from
these programs which really had no no
management upfront and so one of the
things that I the patterns that I
observed as I go and talk to a lot of
enterprise customers who've built out a
lot of api's is that they don't really
set out to build an API program usually
what happens is something more like this
where a project just happens to come
along maybe we're gonna build out
something an angular if somebody says
let's build a new you know customer
facing web site let's build something
for our call center great we're gonna do
that and it just so happens that this
application needs an API we launched it
everything is going according to plan so
far so good until a whole
other projects come along in each one of
those projects needs to create api's as
well so we end up with mobile apps we
end up with cell service kiosk we end up
with all these things that are needing
api's and so then we start to run into
some of the challenges and we start to
see the the need for API management so
if you start looking across these api's
you'll see that they're really not
necessarily consistent you'll see things
like maybe I've got a preferred approach
for doing things like pagination maybe I
like to use limited offset maybe you
like to use page size and you know page
number or maybe somebody else likes to
use a current set of records maybe I
like to use customer uppercase a
uppercase D and you like customer
uppercase a lowercase D or camel cases
or you know all these different sort of
permutations and so what ends up
happening is that as a developer as you
go to try to use these api's you're sort
of having to learn each one over and
over again we sort of have more friction
than we need to have as we're trying to
build API driven applications in our
organization the other thing that
happens is we tend to run into a lot of
the same type of challenges so if you
have ten different teams that are
building api's you may have 10 different
teams that are building out solutions
for things like caching like traffic
management quotas security and so forth
and so not only are these API is sort of
inconsistent but we're spending a lot
more effort than we need to to actually
get them up and running and out the door
and then probably worst of all is that
because these api's are sort of hiding
in silos within your organization they
can be hard to find and so we end up
with sort of API is that that ultimately
do their purpose but we don't get a lot
of the reusability aspects out of them
we don't get a lot of the streamlined
benefits and people aren't able to find
them and usually it's about this time
when companies recognize but we should
get more serious about API management
and how we're going to manage our API s
and so that's when they they typically
start to look at platforms like Apogee
and start to think you know what exactly
is it that we should be evaluating and
what sort of capabilities should we have
in an API management platform
so let's talk a little bit about that so
if you are currently you know you don't
have an API management platform you've
got something homegrown or you're just
sort of evaluating what sorts of
capabilities should we have to be able
to build an effective API program you'll
start to see things like this so we want
to have an API catalog so discovery is
important we want people to be able to
find api's we want people to be able to
use those api's and we want to start
thinking about things like the different
audiences that we might have for those
api's so we want to make sure our
platform can do things like support
internal api's and partner api's maybe
when somebody signs in we want to know
which audience they're in and we want to
be able to make sure that we can put in
place role back role based access
control to ensure that only the right
people should have access to those api's
depending on the types of things that
you're building you might want to have
cell service onboarding so I know in in
companies that I worked for a lot of
times the hardest part of her use was
just being able to track down the API
and talk to the right team to actually
get access to those one of the things
that API management can do for you is it
can streamline that entire process so we
can find the API is they can give you a
way to get credentials the same way you
would expect to be able to go to
Facebook or Twitter sign up for their
API and start using it right away
there's no reason why you shouldn't be
able to do that within your organization
as well and of course you should have
good documentation so this can of course
be things like if you're using open API
for documenting or specifying your API
structure we want to be able to sort of
hold that in but you may want to have
additional things as well you might want
to have sort of longer form
documentation that describes here's how
you get a lot open in our API program or
here's how we expect you to secure this
API maybe you want to put things in
place like SDKs or additional files that
become people can download these are all
things that you can start to think about
as you are looking at the capabilities
that you want from an API the portal
type experience another thing you want
to think about is analytics and sort of
how you're going to track things what
you need to track in the in your API so
of course you're gonna have things like
you probably want to know if all of us
you see a big uptick in errors that are
coming through or a big drop-off or
spike in traffic if things start taking
longer than you expected those are all
things that you want to be able to put
in place and you probably want to be
able to measure business impact to your
api's as well so an Apogee we like to
talk a lot about api's as a product and
taking your api's and productizing those
so that you can expose those to certain
certain audiences these can be things
that are internal maybe you've got
products that sort of represent a line
of business and you want to be able to
offer those capabilities to other lines
of business within your organization or
you might want to productize for an
external audience maybe you built things
internally but they've got some
sensitive information you want to create
something that's more partner specific
you don't necessarily want to go rewrite
that API from the ground up we want to
be able to look at things like product
ization to help with that type of
problem and you may even want to tie
that to monetization so a lot of apple
juice customers actually have taken
their API the data that the data that
they've gained over time and turn those
into monetized products that they offer
to the public or to specific business
partners so that's from a sort of a
consumption standpoint but we still want
to have all the capabilities that we
think about typically with an api
gateway so for example we want to have
in place access control now you might be
looking at things like ooofff as a
standard for API security but you may
need to tie into existing systems in
your your organization currently maybe
you use you know ping for identity
access management maybe you use you know
LDAP or Active Directory other products
that are out there you want to make sure
that you can sort of bridge that gap
between API security and the things that
you have to work with in your
organization likewise you want to think
about things like transformation and
mediation so these are capabilities
where you know perhaps if we have all
those inconsistent api's that people
have built and we don't want to go
rewrite them from the ground up you can
put an API management platform in place
and maybe we can have modernize some of
those query parameters that people have
built we can offer the same uniform
experience to developers without
actually going and rewriting everything
from the ground up
you probably wanna start thinking about
things like traffic management and
quotas so I know I
I did not have a sufficient appreciation
for how complex quotas could be when I
when I joined Apogee it actually seemed
like a pretty simple problem it was I
give you you know ten calls and I'm
gonna increment a counter so it gets to
ten and at eleven I'm gonna stop giving
you access what's so hard about that
and then I a was introduced to extremely
high volumes of API traffic and so if
you start getting things like like five
ten fifteen thousand requests per second
keeping a quota in sync and become a
challenge and then if that quote is
distributed across multiple geographies
it becomes a really non-trivial problem
so these are some of the things you want
to think about as you're looking at at
these gateway type capabilities an API
management of course we have to think
about threat protection anytime that we
go and we want to expose our data out to
the internet especially you're going to
want to make sure that you're thinking
about things like are we protecting
against you know DDoS attacks are we
protecting against people trying to put
in place equal injection cross-site
scripting those type of attacks so do we
have the capability in our platform to
be able to address those and then things
like caching and optimization so a lot
of times we built services that maybe
have been around for a long time back
before we had sort of you know a lot of
mobile use cases where customers
expected a very quick response time so
are there opportunities for us to build
and use caching in our platform to
improve that overall performance and
experience that we can deliver through
API driven apps and so as you go through
sort of this type of an exercise I'm
sure many of you have gone through this
type of an exercise typically you end up
making a selection you decide what
platform is going to work best for you
based on your use cases and it's about
that time that you kind of realize now
you almost have two problems because you
still have all of the API management
concerns that that you know you have
from all the api's that you've built and
all this type of problems and then you
have this new platform and you have to
figure out how exactly we're going to
configure this to build a successful API
API program and so
just like managing anything else when we
go to manage API is we really have to
ask ourselves you know what is what a
success will look like and how are we
going to track and how we're going to
measure success over time to make sure
we're on target to achieve our goals so
in talking with a lot of customers
I've asked I've asked so many customers
you know what exactly do you envision
when you think of an API program that's
successful how would you measure that
how would you think about that and I've
heard of a number of sort of common
themes over time and I've tried to
categorize these so the one of the first
questions that that new customers want
to ask is you know where should we gets
it where should we start and we've we
built a bunch of API should we just sort
of take every API every service we've
built dump it out on our dev portal let
people start using that and that's one
approach it's usually not the most
successful approach where I recommend
that customers start is by looking at
the end user and what's going to provide
value to those end users so I'll give
you an example so I worked with a large
retailer and so one of the first API is
that they they started with that they
really started to publish and and market
was a loyalty program and so we talked
about how they were measuring the value
like how do you know if you're actually
reaching these these end users and so
they did a couple things so one is they
were started to look at traffic for the
loyalty program how many people were
actually coming into their store because
they had loyalty points and redeeming
those points they started to look you
know they got some early signals by API
traffic so as they rolled this out to
partners and directly to consumers they
started to see yep we're actually
getting a pretty good uptick in terms of
people that are taking advantage of our
loyalty program and it's driving those
customers back to the store more and
they can sort of watch that usage you
know in in real time on a day to day
basis the the next aspect once you sort
of have identified that these api's are
going to allow us to provide value that
end user is to convince developers to
start using those api's now for an
internal program that's not necessarily
hard because we've got a little bit more
control over what our internal
developers are building on a day to day
basis
but as you're looking
sort of like public facing API our
partner API is very recruiting people
you want to make sure that you are
offering something to those application
developers and that could be in the form
of a you know better experience new
capabilities and their apps it could be
in the form of a you know direct you
know monetization channel we've got
retailers that are doing things like
revenue sharing monetization so when you
sign up for their API you can actually
drive your monetization of your
application and then when we look at how
customers are actually measuring this
one of the most common is actually
looking at the number of consuming apps
so if we've been able to reach the
audience that we're after we get people
to be aware of those API so they
actually starting to use those and build
those have we built an API that's that's
usable by developers and offer
sufficient value we'll also see the
number of developers that are using
those api's go up substantially and we
can also watch and see how our community
is growing you know do we see more
questions through either directly on our
portal or we're using things like Stack
Overflow we see more interest that are
climbing up and we can measure these and
we can take appropriate steps to you
know continue to encourage that type of
growth the third thing is that the API
is as they're being used they generate
some type of ROI for your organization
and this could be in a number of
different forms I mean this could be
from enabling more partners to onboard
on to your API sort of growing the
partner channels and the number of
people who can sell your products or use
your data it can be in the form for
especially for internal programs of just
greater internal efficiency there's a
lot of time that's wasted by people
trying to figure out there's a certain
API exist what team do I need to talk to
to get access to an API once I determine
that it does exist is there a way that
we can sort of drive efficiency from
that aspect also from the aspect of you
know as people are building those api's
how can we make our applications get
built faster and then we can also of
course sometimes just take the api's
directly and monetize those so we've got
customers out there like a large you
know whether site they'll offer you you
know subscription basis for getting
access to their weather data for example
others that have market data
or accessing things like you know credit
card processing so there are ways that
we can also look at these api's as a
direct new channel of business for our
organizations so when we kind of look
across you know the end to end going
from that end user that's using the
application making sure that we're
driving the ability for the developers
to get those apps up and running more
quickly to use those api's and to ensure
that we're driving the overall ROI we
can think of this as sort of happening
in two parts so the first part is API
exposure so what can we do to make the
ability for API teams to create API is
very quickly more efficiently to be able
to derive the the the proliferation of
API is within your organization and then
we can think about API consumption so
what are we doing once those api's are
up and running to actually make it easy
for people to get access to api's and
start building those things so we can
actually deliver the real tangible value
to our end-users and so again one of the
things that that some of the research we
did leading into this talk was to go and
ask customers you know what are the what
are the actual KPIs that you have found
that you're tracking how do you measure
the value of our API program and so when
it comes to the exposure size sort of
taking all the data and things that
you've built and getting an API out more
quickly we've heard two things so the
first is speed to API so we we've
recognized that need for something and
we want to get it up and running and
available and into the hands of
developers as quickly as possible and we
don't necessarily want to do that just
by throwing more people at the problem
and so we also want to make sure that
the overall cost in order to get that
API out the door is as small as possible
and sort of the key behind this is you
know we're an API management platform
can help is that we can eliminate a lot
of those the the work that you would
have to do otherwise so how can we use
an API platform to sort of allow us to
focus in just on the things that we care
about we don't necessarily want to be
experts of API management we want to be
experts of our API s and
and building the the underlying business
logic and so we can use an API
management platform for things like
security so using API management can we
eliminate the need for individual
security reviews every time an API gets
published can we do things like embed
all those standards that we have and our
standard controls and policies so that
anytime an API call comes in we're going
to automatically apply the the right
policies can we use it to tie in to our
existing IDPs and our existing
capability so that we don't have to sort
of reinvent the wheel every time things
like traffic management so you know we
start to think about some of the threats
that can happen even with data that's
not necessarily sensitive if we have to
be aware that even non sensitive data
can be important so for example we may
have like retailers that have store
hours not a sensitive bit of information
but it's something that's critical for
customers that want to go and look and
see if the store is open is we don't
necessarily want to open that up to the
public have a huge wave of traffic sort
of flow in and take take that capability
down we can use traffic management in
the API management platform to be able
to solve those type of use cases and
protect against those type of threats
again caching will come into play so can
we do things like not just response
caching at the edge but can we also do
things like partial caching maybe you're
built maybe you look at how your api's
are structured and you see that it would
actually work better instead of what you
have today if you aggregate two or three
API is maybe you see from analytics
there are patterns that are happening
over and over again you want to optimize
those api's but you're scared about
handing back stale data so what we might
want to do is we don't want to say well
we're gonna create sort of a mash-up
we're gonna grab two or three different
api's and put those payloads together
two of those things are cacheable we can
use partial caching and one's not and we
can still improve the overall response
time and performance of that API and
then likewise we get to things like like
transformation and mediation so if you
have an API that was built for maybe a
client-server app or something that's
running internally to your organization
and you want that to be useful for a
mobile app you can do things like mobile
optimization we can cut the payload down
sort of trim out the parts that aren't
needed by the mobile app
same thing for like data scrubbing so if
you've got an existing API it's got
sensitive customer information in it and
you want to expose that to a partner
instead of building another version of
that API you can use the mediation and
transformation capabilities scrub that
out so that your same API becomes
applicable and usable by more people and
then of course we want to be able to
track and get real-time visibility into
our API is if all of a sudden we see
that things are going are going bad
either errors are coming up or the
response time is starting to really
trail off we want to be able to get
visibility into that so that we can take
the appropriate action from an API
consumption standpoint some of the
things that we heard when we asked
customers were time to hello world so we
built an API portal we've let people
come become aware of our API s that we
built they can get access to those how
long does it actually take for them to
start building something with it even
just a simple hello world so how long
before we see they go from a registered
user to somebody that actually has an
app that's been sending traffic in so we
want to be able to monitor and track
that that data over time and then
improve our documentation and our
outreach so that we can improve those we
can also look at things like number of
developers so if we're trying to drive
consumption the consumption comes from
developers that are actually building
apps that are going to be using these
API s so we want to be able to see are
we actually getting the adoption that we
want are we reaching the audience of
developers that that we're after and
then are they actually building apps do
we see an uptick in terms of the number
of apps that are being built as we as we
launch more api's and so how do we do
that how can a how can
API management help with that well an
API management program should be
building a very compelling developer
experience for your developers you want
them to not only see here's the
documentation the api's that are
available but also see what types of
things are possible
we've got a lot of customers that are
building things like application
showcases so it's very easy for you to
go and say oh here's a neat app that
somebody built hopefully that triggers
ideas from other developers so that they
can go you know build their ideas with
the portal and you want to make it very
easy for
people to not just sort of see what
api's exists but actually try those out
as well so they can start using those
and they can start experimenting with
the api's and seeing how they work as
opposed to you know writing a little
test harness or things like that we can
actually do that right within the
browser with interactive Doc's you can
take an open API spec load it in create
interactive documentation and start
using that really right away and if we
are able to do this successfully we've
seen some major major improvements from
from our customers so here's a good
example from from Walgreens so they've
been a customer for a really long time
so what they started out with they
actually started out with a an API
called the quick prints API so somebody
at Walgreens recognized that you know we
have all of these photo printers that
are sitting in our stores and everybody
some of you right now are taking photos
with your phones and a lot of times they
just kind of sort of stay on the phone
people aren't printing them off anymore
so what could Walgreens do in order to
make it easy for people to take those
photos send them into the store and
their answer to that question was we'll
build a quick prints API so we'll build
an API we'll put it on our mobile app
but that'll let people take those
pictures send it to the store hopefully
we'll get a little trickle of revenue
that comes in and sort of justifies you
know this space in our store and what
they found is they didn't get a little
trickle of revenue they got a tremendous
boost in terms of those users so the
users that were actually entered in
interacting with Walgreens on their
mobile channel on their store channel
the brick-and-mortar and online we're
spending about 6x
well what anybody else was the folks
that would just come into the store
because these customers were coming in
to pick up their photo and then they
were buying shampoo they're writing
toothpaste or buying whatever else that
they needed at Walgreens and it ended up
being sort of a real eye-opener for them
once they realized that they said we
should open this up we should take this
API and we should let anybody use our
quick prints API and so they started to
offer this to lots of other mobile apps
that are out there that allow you to
take photos and print photos off and so
now they're up to about 300 partner
that are building api's on top of this
quick prince and that's 300 partners
that are constantly sending people into
the stores to come in to pick up those
photos and buy other things at Walgreens
and it's just made a tremendous impact
and so when I think of the successful
API program
I view Walgreens as really the archetype
that I feel like a lot of companies
should strive for because it's not just
necessarily an IT problem it's really
something that can deliver tremendous
overall business value
[Music]